Welcome to the Jonah show today. We have a special guest. We have my ex-girlfriend joining us today
So why don't you introduce yourself?
Yeah, so in case you didn't understand a joke
What I was saying is that I don't have an ex-girlfriend because I never had a girlfriend which is kind of true
I mean
I wouldn't consider the ones I had in middle school in high school real relationships
Because it wasn't really driven by love or anything
It was primarily driven by horniness and nothing else and then in college
It was really hard for me to be in a relationship
And the reason why was because I went to University of Waterloo now, it's not because darn any girls there
It's because we move every four months. So for a month, I would be in scrolling that format. That would be working
So if you meet a girl and you hit it off, you know
It's real nice and then three months later you have to move out and it's not worth being in a long-distance relationship
When you only met each other for like four months, so I think that's the primary reason why I was never in a relationship
And also because I'm a fucking slut by the way new videos every Thursday
I finally chose a schedule. I am going to post on Thursdays from now on at 12 p.m. Eastern Time
I even made a cover photo for it. So it's pretty dope. It's pretty official and
Yeah, and also a nerd thing
Don't forget to follow me on instagram at Jamal pot because from now on I'm going to livestream on Instagram
And the reason why I chose Instagram is because YouTube is getting too big for me and I can't have like a proper conversation
with you guys
So I chose Instagram to make it smaller so that at least I can have more of a conversation
Or I can answer all the questions
Alright, so today I am going to bring you guys to the office
Which is actually pretty cool because I finally got the approval to film at the office
The only thing is that I have to blur everything out
That's too sensitive or that HR said I can't film but yeah, I'm pretty sight. Alright, let's go. This is the gym this
And this is my desk and this is Sunmi the fuck. I'm not some me bro
I'm not even Korean and then now we are at the roof as you can see. It's a beautiful view
Alright, I hope you enjoyed that tour and now it's time to go back home
So now I'm gonna Cameron's I'm gonna say hello terms because it's been a while. I haven't seen them
Yo Cameron was pop it we go. What the fuck are you doing? Dude - what what what is this? It's nothing Oh,
Work
You were say you were coming at 2:30. I just a prize. Yeah, I mean come on man, dude
Why are you filming still do oh my god
You can't trike
It's a little sticky. Oh shit, dude. Yeah, this is actually pretty cool my god. It's so realistic
Holy shit
Alright I'll just do a little bit of coding. Alright, so let me just show you a dope ID. It's called Microsoft Word
I'll have you ever heard of that, but it's pretty damn cool cuz like check us out just like syntax highlighting
You know, you could just change the color like this
Change the color like that
So though, I mean, I don't think any IDE can
Customize your colors that much so yes, pretty much. This is like the dopest idea I've ever used so
Milano's is simple yet truly indulgent treat
Delicate in flavor and texture they have the power of persuasion
stronger than that of words appearances emotions or will
Legend says that no man has ever resisted the temptation of Milano's
Perfect balance of crisp cookies and rich luxurious charm
But they are impossible to find
All right, so I just want to tell you guys I went to VidCon a few days ago
And I actually had a lot of clips so funny, you know, I filmed a lot of people a lot of my co-workers
But I lost it all I'm very very sad. The only thing I have left are these clips?
So we have for the whole weekend I got
We hang out for the whole weekend sort of you feel like
Our bond is stronger now because we feel like it's much worse. I learned that you flirt by trying to quiz people about data science
Say something nice about me so that so that my audience can feel hashtag relatable to me. You know, I mean nice about
Okay, I'll just tell you what to say and you'll say it
Okay, you have to say, you know, Jonathan. No
Okay call you Jonathan?
I've never called you Jonathan because whenever people call me Jonathan it's like more since or warm, but How many people call you Jonathan? Not lot.
Is ..peeep..call you Jonathan? sometimes
like in bed
Is anyone scream Joma in bed
Even like when you're, let me think because that's like kind of funny actually. They knows They
Never say my name's right in bed because it's not like they get excited or anything
You might say other people's name
Yes, say something like Joma
you could seem very silly at times and
sometimes even kind of mean but
In reality, he's actually a very sweet person and it was and that has shown multiple times today
Can you say that? You know.
Sometimes Joma seems kind of dumb kind of mean but uh turns out that's entirely true
I didn't say dump first of all
my god
I'm done for today
Thanks for watching the Vlog. Peace out. I didn't shave because this time I'm not sponsored by Dollar Shave Club
So that's why I couldn't shave but peace
That's what i look linke, when I having sex